par amour il seriez prête à vous
déguiser en elton john oh bien sûr
ouais c'est pas si compliqué j'ai déjà
la couleur de cheveux est-ce que par
amour vous soyez prêtes à casser
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer
c'est possible si possible oui ça
pourrait faire un bon début d'histoire
bonnart c'est possible oui bien sûr les
manuels c'est centre 15 soyez prêtes à
vous mettre à la drogue
non non non et à prendre 17 kg ça m'est
arrivé au oui oui
par amour si on veut qu'il dit je t'aime
avec 17 kilos en plus vous le faites
bien sûr ça n'a jamais empêché 30 jours
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
accepter quelques infidélités
c'est possible ah oui voilà oui je
comprends que vous soyez quasi à
l'unisson jeudi sans mardi l'annoncé
possible
vous accepteriez killing maîtresses très
bon là ça dépend ce qu'on entend par
maîtresse une année avec laquelle ils
couchent fait avec elle qu'elle touchera
8 e temps entendre oui ça me dérange pas
je sais pas peut-être que si c'était de
temps en temps souvent ça me dérangerait
impuissant des fois on sait pas les gens
qui savent pas non leur importance et
quand l'un des deux trompe l'autre un
c'est que le reste du temps ça se passe
bien à la maison mais souvent quand
l'année de trois ans quand il revient il
fait la gueule voilà tout ce qu'on
voulait c'est toi qui me laissait trop
m'étendre là-dessus date étant dé
rentrer à la maison elle est plus
heureuse et qu'elle rend plus heureux ou
qui le rend plus heureux de ça ça suis
heureuse saveur pourquoi pas mais si
c'est pour faire la gueule parce que tu
te mobilises qui rejette tout sur
l'autre comme ça arrive très souvent non
à vivre à trois avec la maîtresse là
j'avais fait un film là-dessus et gazon
ça je sais je crois pas que ça puisse
marcher non je crois pas que ça puisse
marcher à long terme
je parie que samia des couples et pour
qui ça peut marcher parce que c'est sous
toujours le mec qui est cher parce que
le mec et vous avez quand même polygame
lawn par un polygame de nature la femme
étant monogame donc c'est emmerdant et
les clubs échangistes par amour ah non
non non est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à ne plus jamais faire l'amour
oui dame énorme le problème qui peut
arriver il a sauté sur une mine ou un
truc comme ça ça peut arriver
non quand on regarde comme ça mon regard
tombe sur toi sans aucune intention
malveillante
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
changer de sexe c'est pas pensé à ça j'y
réfléchis
c'est à dire que je ne sais lequel on
pense que lui
les jours ses services publics cc amener
les gens à la réflexion découvrir de
nouveaux territoires de juger quelqu'un
jamais pensé sans changer de famille je
rencontre un homme me dis je t'aimerai
tellement mieux si tu es tu en voilà et
le confort y est greffé un pénis et ça
donnerait je voulais pas entraîné cette
somme devrait dire qu'elle est vrai que
les maîtres oui mais est-ce qu'on a
besoin de se faire greffer